in this video we'll talk about vitamin
b9 or folate deficiency
we'll learn what are the classic
symptoms of folate deficiency and the
harmful effect of folate deficiency
vitamin b9 also known as folate is
actually obtained from green leaf
actually folia means
green vegetables or leafy greens
so the major source of folic acid is
leafy greens legumes lentils etc
for example one tablespoon of boiled
lentils contain 80 grams of folate
and one bowl of spinach salad will
contain approximately 75 grams of folate
daily requirement of folate is kind of
around 400 micrograms
in case of pregnancy this demand is
increased and it should be more than 400
microgram folic acid during pregnancy or
when a woman want to be pregnant
so let me tell you why
all women who want to become pregnant
should consume enough amount of vitamin
b9 that means folate
and vitamin b12
because both of these are important for
the development of the brain of the baby
so there is a
neural tube defect that occurs in the
deficiency of folate
now
in the first trimester
the key event that happens is the brain
formation and the first event of brain
formation is neural tube closure
neural tube closure is important for
proper formation of the brain because
when it doesn't close it can lead to an
encephaly or spina bifida like diseases
in order to avoid these kind of birth
defects the mother should always take
adequate amount of vitamin b9 and b12
let's talk about the causes of vitamin
b9 deficiency the causes could be
broadly twofold first of all there could
be dietary deficiency not having enough
amount of leafy greens in your diet
and the second thing is
pathophysiological reasons for example
there could be several medications which
can interfere with the activity of
vitamin b9
such as
anti-epileptic agents
anti
neoplastic agents such as methotrexate
antimicrobials or sometimes even oral
contraceptive pills all of these can
interfere with folate metabolism
other than that pathological situation
like chronic kidney disease conditions
that affect small intestines such as
crohn's disease celiac disease bacterial
growth and parasiteemia can also affect
the absorption of vitamin b9 in the
intestine
then there could be alcohol abuse too
much of alcohol abuse can
reduce your vitamin absorption in the
intestine
lastly it can also be associated with
hemolytic anemia
now folic acid is absorbed into the
jejunum
that means a last portion of your
intestine
and there could be defects in the
absorption that might lead to the
deficiency
now folic acid is broadly divided into
three parts one there is a petrine ring
second there is a para aminobenzoic acid
moiety and third there is a glutamate
chain
now
in normal cases
folate is present in polyglutamate form
but generally it has to be broken down
into monoglutamate form in order to be
absorbed into the intestinal lumen
so once folate get absorbed into the
intestinal cells it gets converted to
tetrahydrofolate with the help of the
enzyme
thf reductase or tetrahydrofolate
reductase and this is a very important
step in multiple biochemical pathways
visual symptoms of folate deficiency
includes mouth source which takes a long
time to heal fatigue and tiredness
now let's try to understand the
biochemistry behind the folate
deficiency so as we have mentioned that
folate gets converted to
tetrahydrofolate and which in turns get
converted to 510 methylene
tetrahydrofolate
so this 510 methylene tetrahydrofolate
is utilized to generate
dna that means the key elements that are
required for dna synthesis such as the
nucleotides one such nucleotide is
dtmp
so dtmp cannot be synthesized if
5 10 methylene tetrahydrofolate is
deficient
so obviously folate is important for dna
synthesis
and this is especially important for the
cells which are dividing at a rapid pace
because they need to replicate their dna
they need to synthesize new dna
intestinal cells has very high turnover
and they are the one which gets affected
by this kind of deficiency because with
vitamin b9 deficiency dna synthesis is
abbreviated and it slows down the
turnover rate
so that is why vitamin b9 and vitamin
b12 deficiency comes with several
gastrointestinal problems
now vitamin b12 deficiency is associated
with folate utilization let me tell you
why
anyway vitamin b12 is really important
for epigenetic changes
so dna methylation is one of them
and in order for methylation to happen
s adenosine methionine should provide
the methyl group
to methyltransferase question is where
does s
adenosine methionine come from it comes
from methionine and indeed methionine
comes from homocysteine
by the way if we walk back we would see
homocysteine is generated into
methionine by the methyl group provided
by vitamin b12
so if vitamin b12 is deficient this
methyl group cannot be provided
and that would lead to a lot of problems
anyway vitamin b12 takes the methyl
group from n5 methyl thf and frees of
tetrahydrofolate which can be utilized
for other purposes
now what happens during vitamin b12
deficiency is
the n5 methyl tetrahydrofolate can not
be converted into thf
as a result folate gets trapped in the
format of n5 methyl thf
now when folate tetrahydrofolate is low
then 510 methylene tetrahydrofolate
cannot be produced
and that is how the dtmp synthesis or
further dna synthesis is abrogated
so this is known as the folate trap
anyway another thing which is building
up is the homocysteine so homocysteine
cannot get converted into methionine so
homocysteine is now excreted into the
urine and
this caused the homocystinemia
anyway low levels of folic acid can
cause megaloblastic anemia
which is a condition where the
rbcs are larger than the normal deformed
in shape and fewer in number
so hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
give rise to erythrocytes as well
so in a sequential fashion the
erythrocyte differentiation takes place
in terms of folate deficiency
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
forms macrocytes which gets destroyed
into the spleen and megaloblast which
are bigger in size they are immature and
they don't have that characteristic
dumbbell shape of an rbc so eventually
these megaloblasts lead to megaloblastic
anemia and reduction in the number of
functional rbcs in your blood
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell can
also lead to myeloid progenitor cells
this myeloid progenitor cell eventually
creates
neutrophils but in this case of folate
deficiency it leads to hyper segmented
neutrophils which is a characteristic
pathological features of vitamin b9
deficiency
question is how folate deficiency can be
detected
one of the great way to detect folate
deficiency is to characterize the
homocysteine level in the urine remember
homocysteine should get converted into
methionine when vitamin b9 and b12 is
present
but when there is a deficiency of folate
it doesn't get converted
and
this homocysteine is now getting
secreted into the urine
so
monitoring the level of homocysteine in
the urine is a good measure
other than that peripheral blood smear
can be performed from where you can
identify the megaloblastic anemia so the
deformed rbcs and also we can
identify the hyper segmented neutrophil
from these blood smeared test
so that's pretty much
defines how a patient is undergoing
vitamin b9 deficiency or not
so you can get
notes and flashcards in my facebook page
do check it out you can also find them
in my instagram instagram page all the
links are provided in the description
you can support this channel in patreon
link is provided in the description and
if you want to support quickly you can
click on the super thanks icon which is
present in the bottom bottom right
corner of the video you can pay using
paypal paytm upi etc
you can follow my
social media which are all provided in
the description you can also follow the
nerd medic channel for exclusive medical
related contents all the links are
provided in the description you can find
them there
so see you in the next video if you have
a specific suggestion don't forget to
put it in the comments
you